today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
there's a super interesting new piece in
the nation
written by sasha abramsky which says
that there are now
even some republicans worried that
indeed donald trump is trying to figure
out
how to retain control regardless
of the outcome of the november election
which is now
under eight weeks away it's eight weeks
minus one day
and they're actually using the word
coup to describe the possibility
of what donald trump may do if indeed he
loses to joe biden
on november 3rd and this article by
sasha abramsky in the nation which we're
linking to and i encourage you to read
quotes charles freed charles freed is a
harvard law school professor still a
republican as far as far as i know right
now
and charles freed is increasingly
worried about donald trump's electoral
strategy
of seemingly encouraging chaos and
violence and is even talking about how
this strategy is ripe
for donald trump to actually send in
provocateurs
into largely left-leaning protests in
order to make them seem more violent
in order to try to justify his
reelection
or as a sort of double goal to
claim that things are so crazy we can't
really be sure the election was done
correctly
if he doesn't win and this is a classic
authoritarian provocateur
strategy we we've seen this the world
over we've seen it for decades and
decades
that's charles freed michael steele the
former chair
of the republican national committee
we've talked about him on the program
relatively uh
well-known individual he is also
concerned about the same possibility in
november
and the the difference would be michael
steele
doesn't so much think that what's going
on is primarily
authoritarianism but michael steele
believes that it's really political
opportunism
and trump being uh determined
to retain control from a politically
uh uh advantageous perspective rather
than simply sheer authoritarianism but
the main takeaway
and the most important point here is
that both charles freed and michael
steele
believe that donald trump is willing to
do whatever he needs to do to remain in
the white house
and trump has been signaling this by
attacking vote by mail
he's been saying he knows the election
will be rigged it'll be the worst the
most rigged most fraudulent election in
history he's said this probably dozens
if not hundreds of times at this point
and has been setting up a situation
where
he lays the groundwork not to accept the
the results of the election and then who
knows what happens
now what we're seeing is that there are
actually republicans
getting together with progressive
organizations
to develop a specific plan for
responding to trump rejecting the
results of the election
if he were to lose and they put together
a report
and unfortunately they're not confident
that our institutions will do their jobs
they are saying it could take
huge numbers of americans taking to the
streets
to make their will be reflected
in donald trump leaving if indeed donald
trump loses the election and claims that
it was rigged
and these groups which again they now
include republicans these are not
left movements uniquely republicans are
also concerned
they're also worried that donald trump
will do something i've been predicting
for a long time
which is that if donald trump is ahead
in certain states on election night this
is the red mirage scenario
trump will deploy lawyers to file
lawsuits
in various states to try to stop the
counting of absentee ballots which if
fully counted
could turn a small trump margin on
election night into a small biden margin
and hand a hand joe biden the presidency
the the indivisibility project stand up
america are two of these groups they're
bringing together a whole bunch of
different organizations to try to have a
really specific plan
to prevent the electoral process from
being undermined and subverted
and disenfranchisement from running wild
now i still maintain
that donald trump will not succeed at
maintaining power if he loses i believe
that he
he will go if he loses but
there is the very real possibility that
he will try
and that he could create absolute and
total chaos for some time including
possibly violence on the streets
ultimately the way that this becomes
dangerous in a physical violence sense
is if it's close and trump wins
on election night but starts to say
they're trying to take it from me i need
you out there
or loses by a small margin on election
night and says it was rigged
i think those two scenarios are the ones
that will most likely
weaponize and that's literally what it
would be his supporters with guns to go
out on the street now there's another
side to this
they are talking about the word coup as
if a coup would be necessary the
unfortunate
reality is that you don't need a coup to
undermine democracy in the will of the
people
because the electoral college has helped
republicans do that in multiple
elections over the last several decades
you can combine the disenfranchising
nature of the electoral college
with the suppression of the vote and
everything else that we're seeing where
you wouldn't even really
need a coup in other words trump may be
able to pull this off
simply with doing enough voter
suppression
enough voter purges etc that the
electoral college hands him a victory
even when he lost loses the popular vote
and really should have lost the
electoral vote as well
the point is we have to be ready for
this and it is not merely the stuff of
imagination
theory and fantasy at this point we've
seen the groundwork laid in real time
proclaiming that this election which
could remove donald trump
uh uh um uh would will be
the most rigged and fraudulent one in
history and my biggest concern is what
is the joe biden campaign doing about it
to be ready
what are democrats doing about this to
be ready because if they aren't ready
that would be a disaster they need i was
going to say just as many lawyers
they probably need twice as many lawyers
as trump has ready
to try to stop counting absentee ballots
they need twice as many lawyers to
ensure that absentee ballots are counted
and it actually could come down to that
it could get very ugly very quickly
i'm not confident that the biden
campaign and the democratic party are
ready why
because they've been not ready so many
other times in history but
they absolutely need a plan they need
the lawyers ready to go
and we're going to be very closely
following whether they do have that
system in place
there are retirees in austria
and other european countries and other
countries around the world who have
received
u.s coronavirus stimulus checks
for 1200 or direct deposits many of whom
have not lived in the united states for
decades
many of whom do not qualify for such
stimulus
payments only u.s citizens and u.s
resident aliens are actually eligible
for the stimulus money that
starts at 1200 and phases out up to 99
000
in income and we have all sorts of
examples of this from around the world
there's a 24 year old
citizen of the dominican republic who
last summer
worked in cape cod and got a 1200
stimulus check signed by donald trump
there's a 73 year old man
from linz austria beautiful place
who worked as a waiter in the united
states for two years
in the 1960s who received and was able
to cash
a stimulus check his wife who never
worked or lived in the united states
received a 1200 stimulus check
orf reports that banks in
austria can confirm that they have
cashed dozens of checks
for residents of austria and it is
unclear how many of them receive
checks without actually qualifying for
them without actually being entitled to
them
there are thousands of foreign workers
who entered the united states on
temporary work visas
who received twelve hundred dollar
checks in error
during that first round of stimulus
payments and of course that money is
mostly being spent in their home
countries
our domestic coronavirus stimulus is
partially going to foreign countries
which i'm not opposed to
in principle but that was not the point
of the plan
129 countries have received at least
one mistaken stimulus check this
includes brazil canada
china india nigeria south korea
and there are a bunch of different
comments about this that we could make
so let's start sort of at the lowest
logistical level
government officials and tax experts say
that the reason for these mistakes
uh include that many foreign workers
file tax returns incorrectly in the
united states
so if you're a foreign worker there's a
particular way
that you are supposed to file your taxes
often
those foreign workers misfile their
taxes as if they were u.s
residents when in fact they are merely
temporary workers
that could be what led to them receiving
a check when they weren't supposed to
receive a check now there's a higher
level discussion to be had here and
there's actually sort of like two
two different discussions one is we have
such a convoluted system in the united
states
from the standpoint of taxation and
filing taxes
that it is almost inevitable that this
sort of stuff would happen
and i know that it might be fun to say
oh this is trump's fault it's really not
trump's fault
what is trump's fault is the the failed
response the fact that he promised a
second stimulus we still don't have
it the fact that we've had six months of
pandemic and just one 1200
stimulus check that's all that's trump's
fault but a lot of this is just our
systems
now some on the right will say wow david
that's you you sound like you want to
simplify the tax code with something
like a straight up flat tax
no no that's not what i'm saying what
i'm saying is that the systems
including the fact that you have
companies like intuit
and these companies that make tur turbo
tax and other tax software
constantly lobbying to keep the tax code
more complicated
that's a piece of this that's a piece of
this we could have a simpler system
without going to a system
that is unfair like a flat tax uh and
then lastly
there is this sort of big picture uh
aggregate economic
element to this which is that of the 1.4
billion in stimulus checks that for
example went to dead americans
30 of that money is still unrecovered as
of the latest report so
if you believe in fiscal of
responsibility and fiscal
conservatism for lack of a better term
uh this has also been a major major
failure
meanwhile there are some foreigners who
do live in the united states
and who are married to u.s citizens who
have
not received stimulus checks though by
every
sensible approximation they should be
entitled to one
and then again more importantly where is
the second stimulus we are now
six months into this congress i think
maybe is just back or about to be back
from vacation
no second stimulus we've got an election
coming up
we've still got a raging pandemic what
is going on with that and that is uh
that continues to be an unanswered
question but at every level
there are aspects of this that have been
completely mishandled
not all of them are donald trump's fault
directly
but certainly uh the the situation has
not been improved by donald trump and
stephen mnuchin and others being at the
helm
and money just flying around the world
some i know in the audience will say hey
that's that's maybe a good thing
uh and sure i mean listen hey we're
supporting different people
i guess but um at if we're not even
properly supporting
americans i think there's a very
reasonable case to be made that money
shouldn't go to austria to people who
aren't actually entitled to the stimulus
money let me know what you think let me
know what you make of it
um yesterday the david pakman show
had our best single day ever
for audio podcast downloads i know i've
said this like eight or ten times in the
last few months
it's because the podcast is growing
dramatically
consider yourself invited if you
normally watch on youtube
one clip at a time but you'd like to
have the full hour show
all at once get the show on itunes get
the show on spotify get the show on
pandora stitcher whichever is your
favorite podcasting app
let me know where you are in terms of a
second
stimulus by letting me know your
thoughts on twitter
where you can find me at deepakman the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com slash
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
sometimes i get a hate mail and
when we have that hate mail read by a
professional voice over artist
we call it hatred mail here's a quick
reminder about that
why don't you take some hydroxic
chloroquine
for that trump derangement syndrome
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
all right let's get uh there's a lot i'm
warning you
i would get the kids out of the room
there's a lot in this week's hatred mail
take a listen to this park man
you're the most disingenuous piece of
[ __ ] on all of youtube
go [ __ ] yourself davey parkman
call me prostitute and patties
loser david parkman doucheboy
wannabe anti-catholic anti-american
leftist
cannot tell the difference between 100
mail in by voter roll and ask for a mail
in ballot votes
my god how stupid are the leftist
dopes most damaging interview
what a clown loser this pompous
jerk is so a lot being said here
and a lot of it is is just wrong you
might be surprised to hear maybe not uh
i am certainly not a communist you know
this is one of the funny things
it's actually similar to what's going on
with joe biden where with joe biden you
have
some on the left who are furious that
joe biden is not a socialist
and then you have much of the right
attacking joe biden
for being a socialist or a marxist or an
anarchist
or a communist or whatever the case may
be in that same way
there's a whole contingent of the
internet left
that doesn't like me they don't think i
am left enough
because i am not a socialist and then at
the same time one of the most common
attacks we get from hatreds is
you communist socialist marxist david
pakman
um the truth is i'm just a social
democrat that that's the very boring
reality
i'm certainly not anti-catholic i'm not
anti-american but what the
what the hatred does get right is that i
am an american leftist
that's true um and this is a trump voter
and
you know we i keep getting calls from
people saying
how can i convince my trump supporting
friend
my trump supporting cousin my trump
supporting parents to vote for joe biden
i don't believe you can that hatred mail
is from a devout trumpist there is no
point
in arguing with them and trying to
convince them
with eight weeks minus a few days to go
before the election
to change their vote they don't care
about facts
they don't care about logic just get the
vote out from people who are on our side
we are better off we are more likely to
have an impact it is far easier to
convince people
who already agree with us that they
should vote than it is to argue with
someone like that
and say no you're wrong about trump you
should vote for biden it's an exercise
in futility
it's an exercise in frustration what's
not an exercise in futility
is using the coupon code hatred 40
whenever you sign up at joinpakman.com
you will save 40
off of the membership of your choice
with the coupon code hatred 40.
and when that code is used i have it on
good authority that hatreds cry they
can't handle it
uh joinedpakman.com coupon code hatred
40.
the president is continuing these corona
rallies
large crowds very few masks
no social distancing certainly no
coronavirus tests
the latest one was at winston-salem
north carolina's airport
airport rallies now are something trump
is doing so he can just
fly in get off the plane and do the
rally
and then fly back out and this stuff
really matters
from the standpoint of the virus on the
bonus show today we're going to talk
about a new study
which suggests that 250 000 coronavirus
cases
a significant portion of all august
coronavirus cases
were spread by the sturgis motorcycle
rally
in south dakota i believe it's not north
no south dakota
um so these events have a real world
impact
let's look at some of the moments from
yesterday's very very much unhinged
rally
donald trump started the rally by
actually bragging about how many people
there were
again during a pandemic no social
distancing very few masks trump bragging
about it
we said let's keep it down they didn't
do too good a job but that's good right
that's good now these crowds i tell you
it's beyond what we had in terms of
enthusiasm beyond what we had four years
ago in 2016
and that was a record enthusiasm and we
are breaking that record by a lot this
is the most
important election we've and speaking of
which by the way
uh at this rally where
there are barely any masks people are
packed together
you really shouldn't have more than 10
people in a crowd and there are
thousands
donald trump attacks nancy pelosi
because she
went to a salon without wearing a mask
nancy pelosi with her hair dryer in the
whole thing
[Applause]
everybody has to wear a mask you must
keep
all beauty parlors closed then she's in
her beauty brother with no mask oh
and then she said the biggest the
biggest person she could have said okay
she said you got me but she said i got
set up by the beauty parlor owner who
happens to be a trump person by the way
i like the beauty parlor first
she said i got set up by the owner of
the beauty parlor now she
set me up i said how you going to do
with putin kim jong-un and president xi
of china
no it's terrible she's always preaching
about the mask you got to wear the mask
at all times indoor outdoor
when you go to bed at night put the mask
on
i've spent the last four years keeping
my promises and
now what nancy pelosi did was stupid
i've already said
you know when these are the rules in
california
you're not supposed to have salons open
she has the money to have someone come
to her house
but who is trump to be criticizing her
for not wearing a mask when he's holding
a rally in the middle of a pandemic
where people are
crushed together it makes absolutely no
sense
whatsoever uh this is the president of
the united states speaking by the way
this this is
the the embarrassment is not just what
he is saying
it's that this is the president and this
is how they speak
then trump went into his performative
mispronunciations of kamala harris's
name
and he starts it's all it's almost like
some kind of gregorian chanting that
donald trump starts take a look at this
by the way you know who's further left
than crazy bernie
kamala kamala
kamala i'm not completely sure
but i'm erring on the side of this
probably being xenophobic in some way do
you guys agree disagree i'm not sure
then donald trump went into the victim
complex
and this is just so out of touch one of
the most powerful men
in the world the height of privilege the
epitome
of wealth um donald trump again doing
the victim complex saying that
he has been treated even worse than
abraham lincoln by the press
uh this is really weird take a look
and actually if we weren't interrupted
with
constant investigations that went
nowhere
and nobody has been through what i've
been through as president of the united
states nobody
you know they used to say abraham
lincoln got the worst press
i said there's no way he got worse than
me but lincoln was very very badly
treated by the fake news
maybe in his case it was real i can tell
you in my case it's fake
it's totally fake but nobody's been and
it should never be allowed to happen
again let's see what happens we caught
them cold let's see what happens
[Music]
but if we didn't have to you know that
takes time and energy and all of the
things the time that we spent on this
impeachment hoax this is kind of like
trump's i did more for black people than
anyone except maybe lincoln
now he's been treated worse than any
president except maybe
abraham lincoln or maybe actually worse
than abraham lincoln absolutely and
completely bizarre
and then donald trump took this sort of
victim complex
and smoothly transit smoothly as
smoothly as donald trump can transition
when alternating between reading a
teleprompter and ranting
he transitioned into suggesting that his
supporters
sign up to be poll watchers on election
day and he warned the crowd
about the stealing and the robbing and
the thieving
that he expects to see it polling places
i guess trump is warning the crowd
about pickpocketing at polling places
take a look
look at these crowds and if they're
going to cheat crowds they're
meaningless really
if they're going to cheat these big
beautiful crowds you can have 15 000 you
could have 50 000.
these crowds are meaningless watch it be
pole watches when you go there
watch all the thieving and stealing and
robbing they do
because this is important we win north
carolina we win we're going to win
florida i just left florida we're going
to win florida
i have to tell you i didn't think that
polling places were unsafe places
it's an interesting idea but it's not
much like we don't hear much about
in-person voter fraud because it
essentially doesn't exist
i've never even heard about theft
burglary
pickpocketing and thieving at polling
places
unless donald trump is of course getting
back to this idea of a rigged election
which he probably is
and then hear donald trump waxing
philosophical
uh to the extent that he can imagining 1
000 years into the future
that his wall which hasn't been built
will still be seen as a marvel of of
human innovation take a look
two things if you come back in a
thousand years two thousand years or
three thousand years
if you're lucky enough assuming we have
something with with the world is a crazy
place isn't it
but if you come back in a thousand years
there are two things with all the
computers and all the everything changes
every day
you invent a new cell you invent a new
laptop
everything is obsolete like about two
weeks after you invented right
two things that will never get obsolete
the wall
and the wheel right
the wheel trump has nothing to do with
the wall
isn't being built and no i don't think
that a thousand years from now
we will still think of a wall between
the u.s and mexico
if it exists as some kind of timeless
marvel
or the vanguard of human technology and
innovation you know we
humans are notoriously bad at predicting
the future humans are notorious
notoriously bad at making economic
predictions
but i feel pretty confident that if a
wall is built between the us and mexico
in a thousand years it will not be
a notable technological innovation at
the time
then trump just starts making things up
about the wall
again going back to mexico is going to
pay for the wall you might not get how
but trump is insisting mexico will pay
for the wall
and you know mexico is paying for the
wall just so you understand
they don't say that they never say it
but we're going to charge a small fee at
the border
you know the toll booths we have topos
they're the it's the biggest border in
the world
in terms of people going across and in
terms of industry believe it or not the
southern border
we're putting a small toll on and maybe
we're going to do something with
remittance that's where people come here
make money
and they send it back so we'll do
something and we're going to
get all the money that we spent in the
mall wall we'll be coming back so
remember i used to say who's going to
pay for it they'd say mexico
like that's right
[Applause]
the fact that trump says this is wild
the fact that a crowd cheers for it is
even more outrageous
there is not going to be a toll there is
it's just not going to happen
mexico is not paying for the wall and
there is no wall
there is no wall donald trump promising
so
trump has it under eight weeks left
to accomplish the promise of a wall
across the entire border during his
first term
eight weeks something like 250 miles of
wall
have been replaced that's what's
happened i don't think he's going
to make it then trump again brings up
this
very dystopian idea of patriotic
education this this is really wacky
stuff
you see what's going on we will restore
patriotic education
to our schools oh you know what i'm
talking about
look at you this is a very sophisticated
group tom
you know what i'm talking about
patriotic education
well the first thing they do is they
want to take your history away
we really don't know what that is and
donald trump has been talking about
restoring
patriotic education for a while now for
a while now in
in schools and what we gather
is that trump wants to correct
what he believes are lies about
racism and slavery i guess that he
claims are being told in schools
he wants to correct that this is his
term not mine
with what he says would be patriotic
education
it's out of this world cuckoo for cocoa
puffs that's the reality
uh and then maybe getting down to the to
the sort of wind down of again like a 70
minute speech the crowd visibly bored
people
on their phones just going on way too
long donald trump
is painting a picture pre-coronavirus
of an america that had fixed its
partisan division
donald trump acting as if his leadership
and his successes prior to coronavirus
were so
out of this world that they had brought
together left and right
when in reality he was impeached and
partisan divisions were worse than ever
take a look at this
and you know what after we get in we're
gonna have tremendous success
and it was building we were at a point
we were so successful before the
plague came in from china we were so
successful
that we were starting to get together
people forget
we were starting success brings people
together it was so good
our jobs numbers were so good and
whether
whether it was the black community the
hispanic community the asian community
our jobs were so good our numbers were
so good
this was one of the least president
at least popular presidents ever
historically
in the gallup tracking poll approval
tracking poll
trump never got to 50 approval
even one day of his presidency and in
fact his election
spurred some of the largest protesters
protests in the united states in a long
time
generating more protesters than we have
seen in a very very
long time and importantly trump lost the
popular vote
3 million 3 million more people voted
for hillary clinton
than the number that voted for donald
trump and trump is framing himself
as having bridged the political divide
up until
the coronavirus hit fantasy world
irresponsible to do the rally outrageous
that we have a president who speaks like
this
the world is laughing at us and yet and
yet
he may get four more years he may get
four more years and we're going to know
very soon
continue uh coverage continued coverage
of yesterday's rally we'll be on our
instagram page
david pakman show on instagram make sure
you're following us there
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program after
too long of a hiatus scott barry kaufman
who's a
humanistic psychologist exploring the
depths of human potential
he's author of the book transcend the
new science of self-actualization uh
it's great to have you back on
thanks it's great to talk to you again
that was a fun one last time
so so let's uh i i have a feeling this
one will will also be
so two words in the title of your book
which we should just
directly get into because they can mean
different things to different people
transcendence first of all and
self-actualization what what do you mean
in your use of those words what what is
self-actualization and what are we
looking to transcend
two woo-woo words right right uh and
here i am i'm a scientist you know i
think there's uh i just want to start
off with that see i think there can be a
lot of wisdom in the woo and i've been
trying to scientifically put this on a
foundation that's grounded in as much
evidence as possible
so abraham maslow the humanistic
psychologist who
really was a big inspiration for me in
writing this book viewed
self-actualization as whatever that
unique part of you
uh that uh that really makes you come
alive that makes you creative
um that really shows the world and uh
that you
truly existed you know when you were
here on this planet
uh transcendence which is something that
that mazzo tours the
the later years of his life really felt
uh was missing from his
hierarchy of needs uh he he saw it as
a great connectedness to others having
um
being at one with your values but
these what he called the b values the
values of being
itself so values which are no longer
means to another end
you know you've transcended uh having
values that are uh
that are perhaps selfishly oriented but
really get
outside of yourself is your um
sense that as you have worked in this
field now
for some time and you of course are
familiar with the history of it and
where
the field is now is your sense that
there
there will ever really be an achievement
of what
a lot of these processes point to or is
it more
this idea that the journey really is the
process and there
is no end point at which we say
self-actualization has now happened and
and we're done transcendence has
happened and we're done
oh gosh what a boring life that would be
if you just if you reach transcendence
and then you were done
right well you just what watch netflix
watch
uh binge watch uh cobra kai the rest of
your life i guess
yeah no i i'm all about the process
really and
i actually define uh the process of
becoming a whole person
a never-ending process it's a process of
integration
your con there's constantly things we
have to integrate we are integrating
various warring factions within
ourselves but it's a never-ending
process
integrating worrying factions outside of
ourselves as well i mean we have
uh various viewpoints and other people
various viewpoints and
these days everyone wants to rip their
head off
that having this sense of um
of a north star of self-actualization or
having a north star of transcendence
means that you're always uh moving
towards it's like you know you're never
gonna
you can see the moon you can walk try to
walk towards the moon you're never gonna
walk to the moon i mean maybe someday
we'll be able to get to the moon
you know by other means but you know
what just having that self-actualization
or transcendence as this this
this moon that you always see in front
of you and that you're working towards
i think is a great north star to have
but it doesn't make any sense that
you're going to actually
achieve it one of the things that's
common in
philosophy and you know reading the
theory of different philosophers
this doesn't apply to all but it applies
to many it's the idea that a particular
um philosophical approach to life
is almost like a grand theory in the
sense that it is the
explanation for uh how things came to be
the way they are or how humans should
interact with the world or it
purports to be a sort of self-contained
package that tells you not everything
you need to know in a literal sense but
in terms of an approach to living covers
a lot of the ground
it seems to me and correct me if i'm
wrong that
you have a sort of different approach
that there is no such
one prescription so to speak
that's right i mean i i cringe quite
frankly when i see a lot of things in
the self-development space
and not i cringe for one reason they're
they're so out of touch with science and
um the actual evidence you you might
have some hyper narcissistic gurus or
something who
uh or uh or people who are trying to
sell a product
who because they thought of it you know
then they're like oh it's brilliant
but but the way science works is that i
i had so many ideas in grad school for
instance that i
woke up in the middle of the night oh
i'm brilliant it's brilliant and i
presented it to my advisor
and i got a reality check you know it
was like actually
that's doesn't make any damn sense you
know
so so you know being a scientist means
you need that humility
right and so i think that the best way
forward
uh is to understand that different their
individual differences you know i i've
studied personality science and
you realize that people are in different
paths of self-actualization
we need to be as accepting as we can of
other people's
uh this might sound but sacred journey
you know i mean there's a sacred aspect
to each person you know that's what
mazda was trying to get at with
self-actualization
he said we don't try to change roses
into lilies we try to make
a rose into a good rose and you know i
think that that's that's really the
philosophy behind this is that you need
to find out what works for you
uh you need to find out what what path
uh
fits your unique constitution your
unique talents you need strengths you
need
personality you know what you see these
days is there a lot of people who are
trying to tell other people how they
should live their life
and it uh it's really it's really truly
unfortunate
i want to get to how much of this is
about the individual
but how much of it is the context in
which the individual lives meaning
society on planet earth at a particular
point in time
but to open that conversation um
we hear a lot about you know social
media
makes people less happy because you're
constantly comparing your life to the
lives of others
technology shorter attention you know
there's this idea that
things are really bad right now in terms
of happiness because of particular
characteristics about society today
how would you answer the question of
whether people on balance are less happy
today than they were at some point in
the past well
you know if you look at every generation
no one is ever happy in
the history of the human species there's
always been
uh i mean there's been obviously uh
prosperous times
um and there's been droughts there's
been horrible times right now we're you
know we're going through a historic
moment right now which
you know 500 years from now they'll
probably talk about as a really
difficult time but but it is too part of
human nature to never be content
to never be satisfied to always um
strive for more to always be unsatisfied
with
um the attainment of our basic needs now
there are
few people who really can cultivate a
really deep
mindfulness practice who cultivate a
really um
a practice where they're seeking wisdom
and and the wisdom they
are seeking is that enoughness you know
but
i do think it's it's part of human
nature every generation you know you
have uh
you have people complaining you know
it's not like uh
it's that unique you know there's
there's some people had argued that
this is the narcissistic generation you
know that but then
and then there's some criticism that
came out well actually you know
every generation of it's just kids are
narcissistic
you know like unless you eradicate from
the gene pool you know
youth you're not going to eradicate
narcissism
to a large degree there's there's
certain things that are reoccurring
because they're part of human nature
what do you make of the uh i would not
what do you make of but
how should the average person who's
trying to figure out their path to deal
with
the the very present conflicts that
exist between
different philosophies and ideas so so
just like one example
the mindfulness movement has has become
very
uh and vogue over the last 10 to 15
years
and um meditation as
part of the path to self-actualization
and transcendence is something that
many people are talking about on the
other hand if you look
at the ancient stoic philosophers like
seneca and marcus aurelius and others
they are not so big necessarily on
meditation
in the sense of clearing the mind
and sort of sort of focusing on
breathing and the like and they have a
different approach
about sort of the practical steps that
someone might take
to solve some of the uh
issues that we might look to meditation
for help with it seems to be sort of a
conflict at least to some degree
how can the average person navigate with
that as one example and of course
hundreds of others the conflicts between
these different ideas about how to how
to live
presently and and transcend for lack of
a better term
well it's a great question and i think
it goes back to your earlier question
about
uh is there one way to live a good life
i
taught at columbia i taught this course
the science of living well
and i had a whole history lecture where
i go through
in depth different conceptualizations of
what the good life entails throughout
the course of human history
and my goal for my students is to see
what resonates with them the most i mean
you do you have the
you know the ryan holidays uh um i love
that guy you know i um
i thought he's been in my podcast a lot
of times and he
he's gung-ho about the study about the
stoics right but but that doesn't mean
that everyone has to be as gung-ho about
the stoke some people might resonate
more
um with uh some of the things the buddha
said some people might resonate more
with
um what david pakman says you know like
like
you you re you really have to uh
open up the space that uh that no one
discovered the ultimate truth
uh that works for everyone in all of
humanity
no one the stoics didn't uh certainly um
now
what could be an interesting question is
what which philosophy is closest to the
science
it's close to actually what the science
shows is
most likely to lead to a good life
that's a reasonable question
and what's the answer to that one oh boy
i've never answered that in public
before
because i'm very wary of uh you know in
some
sort of like uh fight saying there's the
winner
but i think that there are
the science shows that there's uh there
are grains of truth in all of them i
know that might sound like a bit of a
cop-out answer but
it does need to you have to it does i
know right but you have to like
mix and match you know um so
if if i was well actually that's what i
tried to do in my book transcend to be
honest is i didn't
pit it to a particular
ancient philosophy i tried to present
a for integrated framework of what all
the science looks like
so my preferred approach is
science my preferred approach is to
uh to take the what we know about and
put together into an integrated
scientific framework as opposed to a
philosophical framework that's untested
now that might be fighting words to some
philosophers but
about a philosopher i'm a psychologist
there are people who will no doubt
uh listen to this conversation and
they'll say guys you're missing the boat
this is not about maslow this is not
about
stoicism there is no way
that anybody can really uh
self-actualize and transcend unless we
deal with
the structural problems in society when
we have some people might point to
neoliberalism
others will point to capitalism some
will point to the military-industrial
complex or inequality
and they will say what you're doing is
like a retail strategy but unless you do
the wholesale first you're not going to
get there
what would you say to that argument well
i think it's funny that you use the word
boat because that's my new uh
higher give needs metaphor as a sailboat
so
i i very much take in into account and
appreciate the fact that
we can't have too many holes in our boat
or we can't too much insecurity or too
much
stressors on on the boat itself for us
we're not going to go anywhere
but i also try to point to the fact that
we must not neglect our higher
possibilities
either so this is very much in the
spirit of what maslow talked about and
i'm really trying to bring back
a lot of these ideas and make the
argument that we need to work on both we
need to work on security and we also
need to work on growth
if you get too stuck in talking about uh
secure insecurity and uh and
you know safe spaces and um and and
systemic oppress all these things
which are fair enough
but if we talk too much about it we can
start to neglect
and forget that there's still beauty in
the world we can start to forget that
there's still
opportunities no matter what how dire
your current circumstances are
there are still opportunities for
meaning making there are opportunities
for connection
in fact if you if you get too caught up
in what maslow called the deficiency
realm
of human existence and neglect the b
realm or the being realm a growth realm
you actually start neglecting all these
amazing opportunities for connection
that may exist
because you're so focused on grievances
let's pause our conversation with scott
barry kaufman
there we will have the full conversation
in its
total glory on the david pakman show
youtube channel
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as
one dollar per month or as much as you
want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
there is a new poll of ohio voters
done by the right-leaning rasmussen
reports which has donald trump losing by
four points to joe biden 49 to 45 and
this is a really important poll
for a few different reasons first of all
is ohio ohio
is of such importance to republicans and
in fact republicans
a republican presidential candidate has
not won the electoral college
without winning ohio dating back decades
you have to go at least
to the 70s and i didn't go back any
further than that so it
republicans need ohio historically in
order to win
even more so than i would even say
florida
ohio is one of those states where if
trump does not win ohio it could be a
very very bad
election for donald trump this is also
an important poll
because it's a rasmussen poll and
rasmussen polls tend to lean right
if even a rasmussen poll says trump is
losing ohio by four
that could also be very bad for trump
however
you might say this is only one poll
donald trump certainly is still winning
ohio overall right
not so fast in fact in the real clear
politics average of recent polling
joe biden is up by 2.4 on average right
now in ohio
that includes an ohio media
collaborative poll from six weeks ago
which had joe
biden winning there's a poll between
that one and the rasmussen poll
which has donald trump up by one so it
is certainly true
that there's not as much polling data
out of ohio as there is from some other
states
it is absolutely a fact that we should
not get cocky or
arrogant in any way but this
is much like you know when we look at
donald trump being up by only two in
texas according to the recent dallas
morning news poll um when you look at
the numbers out of places like arizona
these are signals about how the election
could go
if we vote if we that's all it is these
are when i see a poll
i see it as an opportunity and it
actually
would make a lot of sense if ohio went
to joe biden
it would make sense because ohio has
been absolutely ravaged by donald
trump's tariffs on china
which i know you all understand this
trump doesn't seem to
when you place tariffs on chinese
products
american businesses importing those
products
pay the tariffs it's not the chinese who
pay the tariffs
when you're in manufacturing when you're
in farming and you're dealing with
counter tariffs from china
ohio is a place that would be very much
affected by donald trump's disastrous
trade policy the point here is
every state has to be involved we're
going to deal with this in today's
voicemail in fact
i'm continuing to uh experience worry
that some people aren't getting the
importance of every state being involved
here but think about it this way
if donald trump is really up by only two
in texas
make him fight for the win make him
spend money
in texas that he won't have other places
we talked yesterday about how donald
trump has already spent 73
of the 1.1 billion dollars that he's
raised since the start of 2019. trump is
in a cash crunch
trump is struggling to continue running
ads in all of the states in which he
should be running ads
make him spend money to defend texas if
florida is
tied or bidens up a little in florida or
trump is up a little in florida
the point is florida is in play and any
money that trump spends in florida
is money he cannot spend in ohio that's
good for joe biden the whole point here
is
we have to run up the score in every
state while
simultaneously keeping the pressure up
so trump actually has to fight for
states that in past elections
republicans
didn't have to put any money into that
would have been easy wins for
republicans that's the way to do it
one other great example of this is
arizona
arizona has been a red state for a long
time
and in presidential elections and on
average
joe biden is currently winning by five
including winning by
nine in arizona in a recent fox news
poll martha mcsally the republican
incumbent senator in arizona is down by
as much
as 17 to democratic senate challenger
mark kelly
it tells us nothing other than the state
is in play and it's worth fighting for
if only to make donald trump himself
have to fight for it that in itself
helps joe biden let's keep it going
we're down to just
seven plus weeks remaining here we're
going to keep the pressure up
we need you to keep the pressure up as
well we had
a fascinating interview last night on
rachel maddow's program
with donald trump's former personal
attorney michael cohen
now i don't really watch msnbc cnn and
fox news
other than services that will sort of
clip notable things for me that i might
want to talk about on the program i
haven't seen rachel
rachel maddow's show in years i think
the last time i saw it was when she had
that
uh episode about um oh we have trump's
taxes
but it was like a 15 year old page one
of a 10 40 or something like that
last night's interview that rachel
maddow did with michael cohen is
fascinating and there's a ton of great
material in the interview i encourage
you to check out the entire interview if
it's interesting to you
but i want to focus in on one thing
today which is michael cohen predicted
yesterday
something we've been talking about for a
while by we i don't mean
i mean you know with the audience it's
been in the ether for a while
which is the idea that if donald trump
loses to joe biden in november sometime
between november and january 20th
donald trump will resign in order to
make mike pence president
in order for mike pence to preemptively
issue a blanket pardon
for donald trump we've been talking
about this for a while
callers regularly ask about it and
suggest it here is michael cohen saying
he believes that that is exactly what
donald trump will do
if he loses to joe biden in november but
you say at the very end of the book that
the president and attorney general
william barr ousted the
u.s attorney in southern district of new
york and tried to install
effectively the president's golfing
buddy as the new u.s attorney there
because the president in your view
wanted to arrange
for himself to be indicted while he's
still in office
because that would give him the
opportunity to pardon himself
after he lost the election i just wanted
to make sure that i understand the point
that you're making there just ask you to
elaborate on that a little bit because
i'm not sure i understand
my my theory is that if he loses
there's still the time between the
election and the time that
the next president would take office and
in during that time
my suspicion is that he will resign as
president
he will allow mike pence to take over
and he will
then go ahead and have mike pence pardon
him and it's a
very let's just say it's a very nixon
type
of event and it was probably
discussed between roger stone and
president trump at some point
that this is certainly one way to avoid
any potential prison time
so there's a few thoughts here that
there's actually a big legal question
here
and often we hear this kind of flat
conventional wisdom that pardons apply
only to federal prosecution presidential
pardons apply only to federal
prosecution
but not to state prosecutions and that
as such
mike pence can't protect donald trump
from state prosecution
the counter argument is that some
believe
a blanket preemptive pardon would cover
state prosecutions the counter to that
would be well
there was the idea that that was the
case with the richard nixon pardons but
it was never actually challenged in
court
because charges were not actually
brought so we don't really know there
really isn't judicial precedent
in terms of the legality or the the
reality
of a preemptive pardon does it cover
potential state charges or does it not
it's a debate is the point uh the other
important counter or or factor is
when we talk about richard nixon's
crimes
they were much narrower in scope than
all of the different stuff that trump
has been colloquially
accused of and they really only took
place when nixon was president
with donald trump we're talking about
myriad crimes
including crimes allegedly committed
before donald trump became president
anyway
and the idea would be preemptive pardon
or not
it's going to be much more difficult for
mike pence to preemptively
get trump out of trouble definitively
that's
sort of one aspect of this the other
important aspect of this entire
discussion
is that clearly the time between
election day and inauguration day could
be very dangerous if donald trump does
lose now that
i have been saying for a long time and
warning people about
and we need to account for that
in thinking about how durable are are
our institutions
how prepared is joe biden and and the
democratic party
and all other aspects of of this country
to deal with what might be armed
trump supporters in the streets between
november 3rd and january 20th if trump
loses and convinces his followers that
this thing was rigged
uh the most important thing here is
trump would rather just win
than to have to deal with even this idea
of
should i resign and pence pardoning me
so because trump would rather just win
he's going to do anything he can
anything he can think of
to win fairly or unfairly and yes our
blood should be boiling about what's
going on
and yes donald trump must be at least
somewhat scared
of what might happen if he does lose but
he is going to try to solve a personal
problem by disenfranchising you
that's where the postal service stuff
comes from that's where delegitimizing
the
trustworthiness of the election is
coming from
that's where all of this is coming from
from so bottom line
i can't see donald trump simply
accepting defeat
i don't imagine that if biden wins i was
looking at one scenario where biden gets
289
electoral i can't imagine that with
biden at 289
trump just says i concede thanks guys i
lost
i think in the event of a biden
landslide trump will come up with
something to
say he's going to start writing
executive orders declaring the results
suspect and trying to postpone a
transition
i don't know he's at least going to say
something about it
if it's close he will do everything he
can to use lawyers to stop the counting
of absentee ballots
he's going to try something i believe he
will eventually go
if he loses but he's going to try
something and we have to make sure
that uh we are prepared for it as i said
earlier i don't know if joe biden and
the democratic party are prepared for it
i hope they are
we have a voicemail number which you can
call anytime that number is
219 to david p
here is yet another caller who i fear
may be understating the importance of
voting if you're in a very blue or very
red state take a listen
hey david i have a quick question i
myself am from new york state
and on the subject of voting i'm
wondering those who
know that their county or state or
district or whatever is going to go
blue right kind of you know regardless
of the
individual vote what would you say to
people like myself and others that
uh might not necessarily think that it's
uh worth going to the effort to to vote
by mail
um or just to vote at all yeah so i
would tell you you are very very wrong
this election in particular is
a crucial election in which we have to
run
up the score by that i mean we need
votes for biden in blue states that
biden will win easily
and we need votes for biden in red
states that biden will very much lose
because the larger the margin the more
difficult it will be for a court to give
anything to trump if he tries to
challenge the results in one state
nationally whatever it's never been more
important to vote
than this year regardless of what's
happening in your
state we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about coronavirus
and the sturgis motorcycle rally
it's not just usps it's also fedex
deliveries that are delayed i'll tell
you why
and my tesla stock my tesla stock down
21 in one day what the hell happened
did i sell any in advance i will give
you the full
rundown on today's bonus show don't miss
it become a member
at joinpakman.com to get instant
access to the bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video